When we were learning
that responsive design,
we saw that a common pattern
was to use the MasterDetailFlow,
which is what were going
to use for Sunshine.
Here are the tablet mocks.
We have a list of forecasts on the left,
and then for the selected item,
we see the detail pane on the right.
This applies for 7-inch
and 10-inch tablet's,
both portrait and landscape orientations.
In portrait mode, the columns
are just a little bit narrower,
but it's still a two-pane UI.
In terms of implementation, all of this
will be under the MainActivity.
Then on the left we have
the ForecastFragment.
And then on the right,
we have the DetailFragment.
On the phone, we would still have the
MainActivity with the list of forecast.
And then selecting an item
would still launch the DetailActivity.
Here's another way to visualize it.
On the tablet, we have two fragments
side by side under one activity.
And then on the phone,
we have the first activity
containing the first fragment.
Selecting an item will launch
the second activity
containing the second fragment.
We're going to break this up
into multiple coding tasks
until we build up the final layout.
First we'll build up
the two-pane UI for tablet's.
Then we'll hook up the communication
between the two fragments
so that's selecting an item
replaces the detail pane on the right.
Then we'll learn how to show
and activated state
on the currently selected item,
so we know what the details pane
corresponds to.
We'll also need to make sure
that the scroll position
is maintained across orientation changes.
After that, we'll update the DetailLayout
so it's optimized for these wider screens.
And then we'll modify the adapter
so that the today layout
looks like the other days.
There's no special
today layout on the tablet.
So hopefully it's clear
how we're going to approach
implementing this tablet behavior
and we're going to step
through it slowly, one by one.